who would have thought that a toilet
could have inspired such an emotional
scene you might need to keep a roll
handy to wipe away those tears the
Regeneration episodes of Doctor Who
always provide a harrowing goodbye worth
having a good weep over but none have
touched the nerve of a fan base quite
like the 10th doctor's farewell with
Rose Tyler often considered one of the
best Doctor Who companions of all time
Rose's time travel Journey came to an
end in the second series of the Doctor
Who relaunch in the 2006 episode
doomsday The Doctor and Rose are seen
hanging on for dear life after the
Cybermen breakthrough of a fracture in
the universe following a prolonged fight
against the scary Metal Men plus the
Daleks Rose falls through the fracture
and is separated from the doctor forever
Hew the tissues it's not until their
final moments together that the true
heartbreak reveals itself the doctor
manages to send an image of himself to
visit rose on a beach in true romantic
style the pair exchanged teary goodbyes
with the doctor Vanishing before sharing
his parting words
sfx magazine voted the scene as the
greatest sci-fi moment of all time back
in 2014 with fans deeply moved by the
Duo's painful goodbyes addressing the
episode 10 years later director Graham
Harper said just as he starts to fade
away from this Dimension never quite
able to get the words I love you out he
disappears completely leaving a
devastated Rose and breaking all of our
hearts on her behalf Rose Tyler
good
dedicated fans might have a difficult
time dealing with any character's death
but when their demise comes completely
out of the blue The Fallout can be
unbearable such was the case for the
season 3 death of Lexa in the CW Sci-Fi
series The 100 after being hit by a
stray bullet Lexa loses too much blood
and dies shortly after as Clark happens
to be the CW's first openly bisexual
main character the decision to kill off
the first woman audiences see her have a
relationship with was immediately
questioned by viewers as noted by
culture S lgbtqia Plus characters tend
to Bear the brunt of unnecessary
on-screen death and many fans felt Lexa
was just another victim in fact the fan
reaction became so volatile that the 100
bosses had to officially apologize as
reported by E online executive producer
Jason Rothenberg second guessed his
decision in an open letter to fans
sharing their relationship held greater
importance than I even realized and that
very important representation was taken
away by one stray bullet it's a scathing
mark on an otherwise successful show
it might have reignited the world's love
for Kate Bush but Max and vecina's
standoff was enough to make any stranger
things fan hold their breath after the
suspensive max escaping vechnus clutches
at the end of volume 1 of season 4 the
final episode proved to be another punch
to the gut for viewers
choosing to offer herself up as bait to
distract vecna long enough for his
physical body to be killed Max's second
pass at levitation ends in snapping
Limbs and blood streaming from her eyes
this is haunting enough without the
added shock of watching a fan favorite
fall at the final hurdle the episode
offers lots of emotion but very few
answers even though the second part of
season 4 has since wrapped up fans are
still mulling the scene over in great
detail including 11 using her powers to
revive Max some viewers have stated that
Sadie sink herself deserved better while
several fan theories speculate on what
The Duffer Brothers might have in store
next what's more redditers believe that
this could only be the start of Max's
problem problems feeling rumors about
season five
it's an age-old tale a vampire Falls for
a sweet Vampire Slayer and the Vampire
Slayer has to kill the vampire in an
unsettling surprise in Buffy the Vampire
Slayer season 2 Angel reverts back into
his evil Persona of Angelus one thing
leads to another and his soul is
restored which turns him back into the
benevolent Angel just in time for Buffy
to have to kill him in order to close a
hell Dimension and save the world
throughout the show Buffy has to make a
lot of noble sacrifices for the greater
good it's kind of her thing their final
farewell for the time being is just as
heartbreaking as you would expect with
some fans still considering the scene as
one of the show's most emotional in the
seconds prior to Angel's death Buffy
tells him to close his eyes before
pushing him into hell she is then left
in tears while trying to process what
she has had to do
in the finale of Marvel's TV sensation
wand division the tables turn for a
superhero people may have started to
feel contempt for throughout the show's
Standalone season Wanda uses her Scarlet
witch powers to take an entire town
Hostage to create the normal life she
has always dreamed of turning from a
celebrated Avenger to a selfish villain
she has been through quite a few traumas
by this point in her story the death of
her parents her brother and her Android
boyfriend on separate occasions but even
Agatha Harkness pales in comparison when
it comes to conniving plans that hurt
many people Wanda realizes how far over
the edge she's gone in episode 8
previously on which includes a flashback
of vision delivering his now famous love
persevering speech but what is grief
if not love
persevering this is the episode when
Wanda begins to see how dangerous she
really can be fans quickly took to
social media to express their heartbreak
and emotion after the episode aired with
Wanda's realization connecting the lies
told by sort head honcho Tyler Hayward
it's a lot to take in for any dedicated
fan but the sadness might just be worth
the payoff viewers commented that Wanda
could now perhaps be seen as one of the
strongest Avengers in the MCU giving her
an emotional Turning Point that's both
flawed and human
preventing the end of the world is no
light feat and sometimes ultimate
sacrifices become necessary in the
Umbrella Academy Season 2's 743 ghostly
Ben leaves the comfort of his spiritual
World Behind by using the last of his
energy to have a heart to heart with
Victor the pair have one last emotional
farewell before Ben disappears into
glimmering blue lights while each of the
siblings put forth their best efforts to
push ahead it's left up to the only
non-living human of the bunch to save
the day his absence from the Umbrella
Academy had a noticeable impact on the
group with fans acknowledging that it
might have simply been his time to move
on
you might be surprised to see Rick and
not Morty appear on this list sure Morty
has his fair share of tear-jerking
moments living out an entire
relationship as well as a harrowing
plane crash before watching it erased by
an accidental timeline reset was Soul
crushing for him though many fans
laughed and saw the humorous side yet
it's Rick that delivers a gut punch when
he finds out his stranger turned Nemesis
Tony the toilet guy has died in the
episode The Old Man in the seat we see
Rick's idea of a private toilet Heaven
interrupted by an outsider intent on
making him pay Rick goes above and
beyond to take his revenge only for Tony
to show him nothing but kindness seeing
such a sweet and polite character last
for mere minutes on screen feels like a
difficult watch in itself but it's
Rick's sudden emotional compass that
really clinches this as an upsetting
moment for fans as one redditor
explained Rick has always wanted
connections that mean something but he
also sees this as a weak part of his
personality in true Rick's style the
friendship that never was still makes
him more bitter than compassionate
in a relatively unexpected move the
sensibility of Casablanca crossed over
into the hit series Star Trek the Next
Generation this specific episode's
existence is somewhat upsetting to fans
as it maintains a meager average score
of 6.5 on IMDb Even while the contents
of will always have Paris fail to
impress its final moments pulls at the
heartstrings fans learned that Picard
and his ex geniece were originally
supposed to meet at the Parisian Cafe
des artiste in 2342 but Picard never
showed up consumed with life on the ship
rather than his romantic relationship
with Janiece Picard opts to part ways
and the two fail to track each other
down the emotional kicker comes when
Picard and Janice finally get to have
their reunion the pair's chance to say
goodbye feels Bittersweet as some fans
suggest Picard isn't made out to be a
great guy after all redditors do agree
that putting this relationship to bed is
charming and that it takes an emotional
look at what happens when things don't
work out the way you hoped they would
as far as Supernatural goes swansong is
an episode that sets fans emotional
pulses racing in the finale of
Supernatural season 5 Sam is assumed to
have returned from hell to see something
he never wanted to a domesticated Dean
the build-up of Sam's realization is
deadly with Lucifer already claiming the
lives of Castiel and Bobby while Sam
offers his body as a vessel Dean finds
himself returning to Lisa the
heartbreaking final scene shows Sam
standing outside Lisa's home watching
the happy family have dinner as if
nothing had happened emotions were
already high before the final scene
aired with redditors commenting on the
roller coaster of feelings between Sam
and Dean in the fight to win back
control yet the final moments cause a
different kind of upset almost acting as
a letdown to what came before even while
Dean assumed he was fulfilling Sam's
wishes of granting him a normal life the
Winchester boys getting domesticated
goes completely against their hunting
nature regardless some agree that it
provides a perfectly teary ending
when it came to its season 3 ending the
producers of Misfits decided to go out
with a bang one of the many catastrophic
fallouts in the episode is the death of
Alicia in an instance of terrible timing
Alicia happens to walk in on an undead
Rachel during a revenge-oriented knife
attack on the Misfits Rachel slashes
Alicia's throat and she bleeds out in
Simon's arms back when it first aired in
2011 Alicia's death made viewers SOB
into their sofa cushions there has been
plenty of fan debate over which death
and misfits was truly the saddest and
Alicia's often comes out on top
according to one redditor her death is
so sad because of its layers future
Simon likely knows what would end up
happening to her and that means their
relationship is stuck in an infinite
Loop the rest of the gang's reaction is
difficult to watch with each of them
functionally powerless and unable to fix
the situation regardless of popular
opinion Alicia's murder is inarguably
cold in kallus and could have easily
been prevented if she was in the right
place at the right time
Star Trek Voyager loses a valuable
member of its crew in episode 23 of
season 7. after finding a colony of
talaxians that he wishes to help neelix
develops feelings for dexa and her son
Brax this leaves him feeling conflicted
after he finishes his mission while his
reason for leaving is very much
understandable his departure is full of
emotion with his fellow crew members
lining the ship's hallways to see him
off neelix leaves Voyager with a
trembling lip and a sense of hope for
his Newfound romance having never been
an official Starfleet officer himself
viewers were left unsure what kind of
farewell nelix would get and the answer
was positively emotional some fans have
since commended the episode While others
questioned why he had to choose between
romance and Voyager in the first place
executive producer Kenneth biller told
sin Escape at the time we often said
what would happen if neelix ran into
thalassians and had to make a decision I
said very early on in the season the
only way I would do that story was if
neelix left
[Music]